Haidee it's actually scaring people the
size okay
[Music]
I'm done with the excuses if you have an
idea and want to create something what's
stopping you
is it the thought of failure
embarrassment or is it the fear of
looking like the odd one out in the
crowd pointing the camera towards your
face what's actually stopping you from
creating a piece of foam
before you ask yourself this question
I'm gonna try to experiment what I'm
about to do I'm pretty sure no one's
ever done on YouTube before because I
mean why would you
it's going to be one serious mission
first and foremost you need an
operational VHS camera from the 1980s
with an extended battery pack the oldest
TV screen you can find the 23rd monitor
one straight will be blank and one round
one I'm a screwdriver crisis justice you
can never have enough cable ties nails
Tupperware brackets and older Mike with
an external recorder and a cable and a
proud I'm going to create a blogging
center from the past in order to make it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I've created this Prime cam to imitate a
traditional vlogging setup in the past
I've given myself permission to create
an entire travel form around the city of
Cape Town with the setup in one day
[Music]
I'm gonna need your help backseat
[Music]
this is a view from chapman's peak drive
just ten minutes outside from the CBD of
Keita
check it out
[Music]
the mountainous landscape in Cape Town
offers hundreds of caves just like this
one we've only shot one shot and I swear
I've never worked this hard to make him
fit before
[Music]
one of the things we have in the
speeches
[Music]
[Music]
yes the struggle of the glorious life
behind the scenes of a vlogger in the
early 80s the soundest thing makes this
legend ooh it's like a crooked pram from
a horror film
[Music]
we are headed to the helicopter now to
try and get some sort of an aerial shot
[Music]
[Music]
a bride with my own
[Music]
shooting on this camera is the biggest
mission where you're going
three I'm so over this old-school piece
of shut up a third a footbridge it's
been fun
old VHS
[Music]
you guys really think I was gonna throw
that over there
shit's expensive slow dramatic effect us
as a generation of content creators
should stop taking technology and the
tools at our disposal for granted I
think it's a good excuse I think it's an
easy excuse to use the fact that we
don't have the tools we need to be able
to shoot something and that's ridiculous
because I understand it being a creator
myself the most difficult part is
actually getting out there and making a
film it doesn't matter about what other
people think it doesn't matter if they
say the quality isn't good enough it's
about getting your idea out there and
being heard and getting your voice heard
and I just I guess I created this video
so that I could inspire content creators
just to create more that's all just get
out your phone get out your DSLR get out
your drone your GoPro or whatever it may
be your webcam and just shoot your idea
stop making excuses I'm so stoked to be
back on YouTube I went through the same
thing I stopped creating video I just
didn't think I was good enough and now
I've decided to just start shooting
every single idea I have if you like
this form let me know in the comments
below and please subscribe every
subscriber Hubbs
Cheers hey things it yeah Oh